definitely I felt like in a little bit
of the same boat since the final season
part two just saying it out loud is just
so T yeah I started to kind of check out
a little bit mentally I think I was like
losing my like I was like okay are you
serious yeah I kind of really final
season part two that's I genuinely felt
like it was one of the like more boring
sections of the show for
me because oh my God uh talkie talkie
talkie talk don't don't mind him talkie
talk
I'm I'm dying here yeah you can you can
take it uh you know there's a there's a
very big reveal at one point during the
show uh to do with uh well there's many
big
reveals oh let's let's let's uh think
about some of like the small things that
happened in uh the second season oh
let's oh wait what was the opening
called again uh the rumbling oh that's
that's like a tiny event that didn't
have any impact on the major
story s yeah the song was the best part
of that I
I the rumbling when that started
happening I I felt like it was genuinely
just
boring there is so much we got to unpack
here
why um boring yeah I I I kind of liked
there was the reveal before this where
it was revealed that Aaron had an
ability that we didn't know about um
that was that had a bearing on the
entire story and I thought that was
really cool and then they just started
going on and on about the backstory
about where this all came from and it
just started to feel like I was like and
I know I know it's not but it started
feeling like super bloated for me in a
way that I then also didn't care about
the rumbling because I it felt like oh I
know I know how this is going to end
like this feels like it's it's going in
a very clear Direction and they made and
to me it was like okay Attack on Titan
was always at its best when you didn't
know where it was going yeah and you had
no idea what was happening next see and
I felt like that once the rumbling
started it was kind of set into this
motion uh where I I thought it was just
going to go a direction and it
absolutely just did go the the what I I
mean it's it's a very safe direction is
the direction it went in I was so
checked out watching that season I don't
even remember
that it felt like
they like you were talking about it what
am I dealing with you were talking about
and I'm like oh yeah that did happen I
just wasn't paying attention Okay there
was a few episodes the next season where
I felt like they were just [__]
wasting time I I think the complete
[__] opposite really because like I
when I saw everyone was very annoyed
because one thing I did notice I somehow
managed to go spoiler 3 so I didn't know
anything somehow I went into spoiler 3
as well however I did know that people
did not like the ending yeah and
therefore I thought the ending was going
to be something kind of weird or kind of
unusual but to me I felt like the ending
was about as safe as you could have gone
uh yeah to me the ending uh I can see
why people had issues with it cuz I
certainly thought that okay I I I think
I really liked the ending I thought it
was very messy uh in the way it was like
well that's getting me excited to watch
it it was messy but it was literally the
safest outcome it was like if you if you
were telling a story and you wanted to
wrap this up how do you do it in the way
that you think will probably be the most
conclusive in like a and satisy yeah and
we'll kind of be like a nice little bow
on the story right right um so that's
what I felt I don't know yeah but yeah I
agree was convoluted and kind of blow I
think it was messy yeah it was it was
like it was it was mess well we'll get
to the ending like eventually but cuz I
I I can't let go of this like final
season part two yet okay um sure sure
sure because you know I thought that I'm
trying to think of if there was like a
weak point of it and I would say the
part that disinterested me the most is
probably like the law Parts um how I
describ the LW parts of Attack on Titan
with the Titans and stuff like that it
kind of felt like okay you're watching a
horror movie and then there's like this
mystery monster right and then they
reveal the mechanics of the monster and
you're like ah the charm's kind of gone
you know it's it's kind of like you have
to do it because hey you've built this
mystery up and hey you need some kind of
explanation but there will never be kind
of like that kind of so you can't look
at Titans with the same kind of fear or
Mystique or whatever yeah I don't know
why they couldn't have just gone the EO
junji route and just never explained the
mechanics and just left it a mystery
I mean so much of the they were building
up to explaining it yeah they were
building up to explaining it and uh that
was definitely like my least let's say
the the part of attack fight that was
interested in the least pretty boring
bloated um but I still I still thought
it was like pretty interesting in terms
of what that meant for you know each
character and how each character deals
with these
Revelations the [__] rumbling and
especially one of my favorite parts of
final season part two wasn't so much the
event of the rumbling itself it's how
you have all these characters you've
built up all these like two in my mind
interesting characters and you just get
to see how everyone in their own way
deals with it and tries to cope with it
you know I thought that I I thought you
you this is what happens when you just
take great characters and put them in an
interesting situation uh one of my
favorite scenes is uh just when bunch of
these characters are just sitting around
a fire pit no action just pure dialogue
and I was just like they are just
talking and discussing what happened and
discussing all the journeys they took to
get there and it's just this is like
compelling television when you just when
you have characters that have built up
you've built up this much that all you
need to do is just put them in the room
together and you're like all right
Magic's going to happen yeah and I I
enjoyed that segment uh it was when they
in during the final season part two they
get to this docking Village uh and
that's when I was like what the [__]
this is so boring docking Village get to
the the village with the port sorry oh
yeah uh I love that scene what you mean
it's it's like it's like seven episodes
where they're like at this place it's so
long I don't know how many episodes it
is you mean you mean one where they're
stealing the boats yeah but they they're
around that area for quite a while and I
was like hurry the [__] up oh yeah that
did
happen I was like what are you guys
talking about I'm just like yeah I'm
trying not to get too
spoilers but there's just this yeah and
and to me Attack on Titan I think the
best season of second was season 3 yeah
season three part two I agree with that
what season three part two which which
one is that it was it was two part
remember oh right right
right I was like what I I kind the
ending of season I think I think of all
of that is three I I don't know no it's
two it's two parts it's two parts right
what was a year in between yeah season 3
part two I suppose yeah is what I'm
referring to is my favorite but also
part one of season 3 was also really
really good oh yeah it's one part three
sorry Season three part one and two I
really like the most and that's when it
was I think at its best for me and then
we had that big reveal yeah uh with
Aaron and then it slowly started to like
taper off for me in terms of interesting
because I felt like then they started
the the or it turned into a different
show yeah it was more it was more about
why the [__] this thing is giving Titan
powers and then suddenly I felt like wow
this is the weakest part of the show yet
and I watch season two of the show no I
think the weeks SP was like season one I
think season one you kind of get like I
haven't rewatched it so I think if I
went back and rewatched it I might think
it's it's way worse yeah um I I feel
like I just need to binge all the
seasons now this I do need to go back
and binge it and come back to this
conversation this is like I cuz this is
like 10 years of scatterbrain memories
I'm trying to critique a show when I was
[__] 17 and I watched it the only
thing I remember is the dub scream from
yeah I mean cuz I have like rewatched
the show multiple times maybe not like
valid maybe not like the entirety like
recently but I before like the last time
I rewatched the show was before the
final season came out I was like I need
to refresh because it's been a long time
um totally worth it for me I I actually
think I might have enjoyed it more
during my rewatch because now that you
have now that you have the context of
all the reveals and everything that was
kind of like part of the mystery of like
eron's basement and stuff like that you
realize holy [__] this was all planned
from the start yeah you can see all the
little hints now right yeah yeah yeah
yeah there are so many hints from season
one that that out of context I just like
completely blanked on cuz I'm like this
scene makes no sense why why is the
scene and then you watch it you're like
oh [__] this is like final season stuff
what the [__] knew from the beginning
yeah yeah yeah it's it's it's insane
rewatching all of Attack on Titan yeah I
do want I do want to get back yeah but
you know part of part of the thing I
reason I think season one was uh the
weakest is mostly just because you are
kind of like setting up the world and
the characters and it did like Aaron was
at that time a much more boring
character oh God he's so boring um was
just a child I I mean [__] [__] children
bro yeah yeah [__] children I mean the
the point is you had to establish him as
like an angry angsty teenager uh who
just was like [__] prone to violence
and it was the initial hook it it was
like it's and like at the time I was
just like oh he's just like every other
edgy Shen protagonist out there um and
then you see his growth and evolution
and that's where the payoff comes in but
still season one I it's it's it it was
more exciting because of the action
scenes um rather than the kind of like
me being engrossed by all the character
writing and everything in the character
writing everyone used to say that it was
Game of Thrones of Ane that because Game
of Thrones at the time was really big
wait who who the [__] was saying that
everyone was saying everyone everyone
was saying everyone was like it's like
Game of Thrones for anime everyone's
dying it's like it's like people die
equals Game of Thrones well because that
was the that was like the that was what
dominated the sphere of conversation in
like early uh 2010s G gaming with
difficulty ah it's the Dark Souls Dark
Souls it's the Dark Souls of hentai game
Thrones with less tears come not
come
character writing okay it's interesting
you say that you think season one was
the weakest because I think the general
consensus when everyone is comparing all
the seasons to one another I think the
major consensus is a lot of people say
season 2 was the weakest uh season 2 was
when I actually started getting invested
in It season 2 was when I kind of
realized that oh these characters are
actual like characters with depth uh and
their own goals and it was a ser series
that was willing to put focus on other
people rather than what I thought they
were there also a lot less action in
season 2 as well I think that's what
like pushed a lot of people back yeah
season two was set up but even so just
seeing like the focus on Y and Historia
who were a big part of season 2 and I
remember like watching season 2 I was
like okay when are they going to get
back to like Levi and and the main
characters characters The Big Three who
who are these two little lovers who are
we didn't see anything about in like the
first season I think also cuz it was
there was a fouryear wait I think right
between four year wait four year away
which was like and every everyone was
[__] waiting for the second season
and then that's what came out and I
think people were like what the [__]
yeah and then I I think it really hit me
at the end when I was like [__] I
actually really care about these two
people maybe even more so than the main
characters and I was like oh okay this
is this I'm actually getting invested
like properly invested in someone
because before when youd have a
character death in season one it was was
just like uh aha we've we've known this
person for like one episode like uh you
know like oh oh it's the Levi squads oh
wait no no it's just Levi okay yeah it's
just Levi and I'm like I guess that's
sad you know but it it like it was
obviously like very impactful mostly I
think because of like the direction and
the music and everything but how much I
actually cared about anyone who got
often season one was just like yeah it
was all like shock Factor whereas season
2 I actually started giving a [__] about
just started giving a [__] about
characters that had absolutely no screen
time in season 1 and then like the
absolute [__] balls of this man to do
one of the biggest reveals um just in
like a piece of like side dialogue do
you remember this the Betrayal scene oh
yes and then you know you know you were
expecting this kind of like big reveal
to be like haha I am this person it is I
it is I it was me all along yeah but
time time was just like by the way it's
me yeah yeah and but yeah and in Attack
on Titan it was just like a piece of
dialogue that was going on in the
background and you had to like literally
double take to be like wait wait did he
just did did what did and and and I was
like this is like the most genius way to
do like a big plot reveal like I've ever
seen cuz they like completely subverted
expectations so like even season 2 was
like the slower season had so many like
amazing point one of the best moments in
the show I think it was a really
highlight yeah I think I feel like you
know the I remember cuz there was a time
when I think it was just season 2 that
had come out and a lot of people were
comparing it to season one and being
like and you know obviously not knowing
where the story was going so they looked
at season 2 which you know had a lot
more new characters that you had to get
yourself you know invested into and less
action so people were immediately like H
season 2 not as great as season one but
again like I think it's after when until
after season 3 came out that people
realize that it was just a setup for
season 3 and then everyone I I think
that's when the appreciation for season
2 slowly started to come back but
there's still a lot of people who say
season 2 was their least favorite yeah
yeah I I can see why generally overall
it was but maybe maybe the final season
part two is M's favorite I don't know
yeah I mean I think uh I don't know I
can't really think of a season I really
like didn't like you know there are like
weaker Seasons but overall the final
season as a whole I think the latter
half I think there was like still like
super like interesting things happening
like to me like the rumbling and or like
the reaction around that um I think
season 4 was just really compelling
character drama before that I was still
like really really invested in the
action scenes as well like you know
seeing like humans versus Titans season
4 it was just like H war is war is war
war never changes and stuff like that
I'm like okay I've seen I've seen this
kind of thing before uh the action
scenes which were equally as hype I was
actually less interested in the action
scenes than just see seeing characters
well yeah because it turned into a human
drama yeah yeah it's just seeing
characters like talk to each other some
of my favorite scenes in season 4 were
just dialogue scenes like Aaron uh Aaron
like talking to um Rina in the basement
that was just like you could just cut
the tension with a knife in that scene
and I was like this is this is just
compelling television and I [__] love
it um so I don't think that there was a
bad season of Attack on Titan I think
there were weaker Parts but I think
overall attackman Titan to me with this
ending which I was very very scared of
because I had heard of the um opinions
of the manga readers but now that I've
watched it I don't think it was the
greatest ending in the world but I think
it did the job and I think most
importantly it kind of like cemented
that attack on Titan to me is is kind of
like a modern classic you know I think
yeah they should stick The Landing right
I I think you don't You' already got
such a crazy story and the a backstory
that is really already way way
complicated and I feel like you just
just do a simple ending right don't
don't do anything crazy I think that's
what they went for yeah um what did you
think of the ending yeah I thought it
was fine it was exactly what I thought
was going to happen like the moment with
the fourth season part one whatever the
[__] started it was just clear that it
was going there like it was there like
you know I I couldn't see it the fact
that there could have been another
alternative ending but I don't think
they would have gone for it they they
didn't try to challenge it or no I felt
very obvious what was going to happen
cuz is it true that the ending to the
anime is slightly different is slightly
different so I I had to look into this
cuz I was like I I need to know why the
[__] mangar readers were so pissed off
right uh some of it completely [__]
stupid and invalid uh like it got to the
point like the complaints or the ending
um the complaints oh right right like I
like from what I understand and mang
readers you can you can tell me if I'm
wrong cuz I didn't experience oh they
will okay there there are some things
where um I'm like there was one line can
I can I say this line sure sure okay
spoiler theno there there was a line
that was changed from the manga to the
anime and it was a line where Armen
thanked Aaron for becoming a mass
murderer what is he what is he a true
crime
YouTuber that was based content Aaron
you did a good job kind of high 20 part
series out of this thanks yo your KD Rao
through the roof and I'm like oo that's
that's a spicy line right there um so
they changed that in the anime yeah so
they they changed that in the anime to
just um Arman telling AR uh sorry Arman
telling uh Ain that uh Hey see you in
hell [__] right and uh you know
it's I I kind of understood makes more
sense yeah yeah I kind of understood
like the intention of that line which
was just Armen kind of like trying to
even though he knows Aaron's a [__]
bad guy and did all this bad [__] that
he tried to take some of that guilt
along with him because he still sees him
as a friend right the line just came out
it just doesn't
translate I mean there's like I wonder
if it was a translation thing as well I
mean know what the original I need seen
in Japan yeah I'm I'm not sure but I
think some of it was just that there was
just so much kind of like anticipation
for the ending right that I don't think
any amount of hype that mangeras had the
expectations uh was going like was going
to be met by the manga ending at all um
because I think luckily manga readers
took the L for us because I think pretty
much all of our expectations were
tempered a little bit yeah yeah uh
because because we saw what the manga
readers we have the exact line uh Arman
says thank you for turning yourself into
a mass murderer for 's sake oh it's even
worse than what I
said for Al's sake oh and uh say
expresses regret towards this line of
dialog admitting the intent of the wood
didn't come across as as he yeah yeah it
is crazy how you just [__] up one line
of dialogue and it's like well uh every
every thinks your story sucks yeah yeah
um but I yeah I imagine if he regrets it
then I imagine he probably told the
anime staff or what they had a
like Hey I what I meant to do something
different here